is there a scientific is there a
scientific way
to figure out what it means to be gay
like meaning there is a scientific way
to say what is it to be a man right
scientific I'm born with a dangling
right yeah there is a scientific I think
that's what they call it right somebody
clip that please yeah
somebody's gonna
that one's done there's a stem on the
Apple yeah that's funny a girl is born
with a vagina right like that movie what
was a kindergarten cop hey when he tells
uh Arnold schwarzeneg he says what he
says you know boys have penises and
girls have vaginas right okay that is a
scientific way and we can even go deeper
to look at the chromosome count to say
this is there a scientific way
of defining what it is to be gay or do
we all just have to say well you said
you've been gay since you were kids so
we have to believe it it do you know
what I'm asking Tom is there a
scientific way to say based on your
chromosome count and where you're at
you're gay
um I haven't seen anything like that
um on my end it's it's something that I
would foresee being very hard to
determine
um you know because people go through
these these life experiences and changes
you see it all the time where someone
will be like you know 55 and say you
know what I'm really gay and then they
start liking men and it's like how do
you really gauge you know um how do you
quantify that experience to be able to
make a determination on it you know who
you see that a lot with too truthfully
in my experience I've seen a lot of
women who go through life they have a
family they're married they have kids
and then at 50 they're lesbian which is
and I reason that this is an interesting
point that I know you've brought up a
couple of times Pat I think is because
if you look at the stuff like with Bill
Maher that we talked about before the
numbers are exploding if you look at the
numbers of when you talk about trans how
many people you know who are
legitimately have you know body
dysphoria or have all of these issues
those are also ballooning so there has
to be a way to gauge like what is real
what is happening in someone's body
versus what is societally induced in
someone particularly with respect to you
know I'm a boy I'm a girl I'm this it's
you can't just treat people based off
nothing right they're now getting drugs
and stuff it has to be grounded in some
science here have I told you the story
about the gay bar we went to in
Nashville Tennessee I know you don't
know the story but do you know the story
okay so I'm the Army and one of our guys
his name is Chip he says
when you're ready I want to take you to
the best Underground club in all of
Nashville I'm like bro I'm ready I've
gone to all the clubs I've gone to Vegas
trust me I'm ready he says no you're not
I'm telling you I've been to a lot of
crazy clubs I guarantee you've never
been to a crazy club like this I said
dude I'm I'm from L.A he says okay let's
see anyways three months later he's like
the guy that's been there longer than us
he takes me and this other guy Jeff to
this club we go to this club it's Studio
54 on steroids and by the way when I
tell you Studio 50 if you've seen the
movie where people are going at it on
the floor they're doing this over here
they're doing that they're doing this
trans drags all of it is going on at
this club okay and there's a couple
thousand people there it's Bonkers how
crazy this club was so we go in
we go in and obviously uh you know gay
men will come up to you and say hey
handsome hey
what voice because it's floating in
their own way and then there's those
that don't have the deep voice and they
talk to you as well right like all right
cool so I'm like listen man I'm just
here for the girls and it was great
because girls would go there to not be
bothered right because they just want to
be left alone well this allowed us to go
there and if they change their minds by
11 30 there's an option
you're like okay cool we'll go there
guys there's plenty plenty that have
that same Outlook right assure you so
I'm like you know what what a brilliant
strategy by this guy so I'm like why
does this guy always around these
beautiful girls anyways here's what
happened on the drive home one of our
guys
goes to the bathroom and this guy
approaches him and he says uh you know
you gaze is now I'm straight he says you
ever been with a man before he says no
he says how do you know you're straight
if you've never been with a man before
okay
and in the 45-minute drive back from
Nashville to Fort Campbell Kentucky this
guy was struggling with that question
really and I'm like I'm like bro what
are you doing I said this is he's
supposed to do that that's kind of like
how we flirt with girls we use our like
you know the line from uh Top Gun he
says you know uh you whatever you you I
don't date Pilots well if the government
can trust me why can't she
okay straight guys he's like no but but
what if he's right I'm like oh you don't
understand what you're doing bro right
now you're gonna go in a very bad place
here going down the rabbit dude until
we're married we're all in sales guess
what Rabbit Hole he ended up going to to
the rabbit hole to find out for himself
oh I'm not even kidding with you so he
goes bad I was like more than a rabbit
yeah well it is well he goes back and he
fully wants to find out
and then anyways I don't want to go into
some of the people that listen will know
who I'm talking about he ends up saying
no you know I'm not I'm straight okay
but if full-blown went everywhere okay
he was all in like did you really have
to do this to go there he said well yes
so the reason why I asked that question
is because I think
it's uncomfortable to talk about this
today because I know what's going to
happen after this podcast today I'm
going to get emails why are you even
doing this stick to the business stick
to that okay you're talking politics why
are you touching this you know these
guys are going to come and they're going
to do that and they're going to do this
I'm asking a simple question if you're
saying 75 25 because of Life 75 they
were born that way I'd love to know the
scientific formula on what categorizes a
person to be
gay and then we will I mean I think it's
like dude what do you want to say that
person based on that or it's just a
choice an individual is making that
later on a lot of it could have been
persuasion by somebody else because from
my experiences I've been you know I've
been to many different places and I've
been around Straits gays pies all of
this stuff and I understand I understand
what the approach of trying to convert
and baptize the other individual to get
them to think uh so my my question is
more I would love the research to know
exactly what that number is and I would
love for scientists who are Republican
and Democrat to work together fund the
budget to find that exactly what needs
to be the scientific formula for us to
say people are born gay I'd be so
curious to know that I think that that's
something under the Wheelhouse that we
can definitely
um you know deep dive into as an
organization we're definitely um just
you know got non-profit you know for the
IRS so we're definitely seeking large
funding to be able to you know pull
things out and accomplish things like
this because I think that there is a
gray area that um you know what I mean
yeah that isn't being investigated and
that's something that you know gag could
definitely look into because it goes
under the grooming wheel you know what I
would want to know I would want to know
if you can pull up
if you can for a fact get to the bottom
of it and fund this with Scientists I'd
love for your organization to come back
and tell us how much that would cost
okay and you got it yeah I would love
for you to come back and say we can fund
it with this scientist that scientist
and I want it to be both sides because I
don't want to be any bias they're all
Republicans or they're all Democrats or
all this I wanted to be people at our
for the vaccination they're not for the
vaccination I don't want all of them to
be well the vax wasn't a good thing you
took or I don't want all of them to be
you should have taken a vax for Kobe
because you know vax became political
this LGBT is political everything is now
political of course if you tell me how
much it would cost to find out to get to
the bottom of it I don't know maybe I'll
either contribute or we'll go help you
raise the funds but I'm really really
curious and what I'm even more curious
about
has this study ever been done Rob can
you even pull it up like is there what
is like uh what would be the word by the
way to even search for it is a gene is
it a chromosome what would it be like I
feel like it would be something like
like in your brain activity would
probably be like where you would want to
Target
um you know certain receptors I would
assume if you were gonna gauge because
at the end of the day it's based on your
attraction right PBS so pull up that one
let's see what PBS says can you pull
that up there is no gay gene there is no
straight Gene sexuality is just complex
study confirms
can you zoom in a little bit so we
obviously know this is PBS so we know
what side they're going to be leaning to
there's no single Gene possibility you
know the first thing you need to know
about the largest genetic investigation
of sexuality ever which was published
Thursday in science the study of nearly
a half a million people closest uh the
door on the debate around the existing
of the so-called gay gene okay in it
instead the report finds that human DNA
cannot predict who is gay or
heterosexual sexuality cannot be pinned
down by biology psychology or life
experiences this study or other shows
because human sexual attraction is
decided by all these factors this is not
a first study exploring the genetics of
same-sex Behavior but the previous study
were small and under
powered the study's co-author and
genetics research fellow at the broad
Institute and Mass General Hospital on
Wednesday just to give you a sense of
the scale of our data this is
approximately 100 times bigger than any
previous study on the topic the study
shows that the genes play small and
limited role in determining sexuality
genetic heritability all of the
information stored in our genes and past
between Generations can explain eight to
twenty five percent of why people have
same-sex relation based on study results
are they going to give it to us or no
contract on a single Gene keep calling
now let's see if there's like points
what they're going to say so what keep
in mind of course ethical concerns yeah
I I don't know if if I know what
physically I can say somebody is
straight somebody is a man or somebody
who's a woman I'm not talking about
straight or gay I'm talking about what
is a man and what is a woman okay we can
physically look at somebody when they're
born when the someone your baby is born
they will say you have a boy okay and
when we see the picture they'll say this
is a boy because of you know you see the
picture there's a dangling right or this
is a girl right and you go you got a
girl you got this okay great now oh it's
a boy phenomena you celebrate but is
there a way to say your kid's going to
be gay because his chromosomes number is
this and test is this this is what's
going to happen great let's celebrate it
right yeah I think um that's going to be
a really hard thing to to accomplish
because I I did read a study like
through the the National Library of
Medicine that that kind of reinforces a
little bit here that there are many
influences that can help determine or
I'm someone's sexuality and I think um
I think that that would probably be most
accurate that sexuality isn't just
something that is so binary that oh you
can only be straight and you will always
be straight I think we have enough you
know people in the world that have
changed that like we spoke about but um
when it comes down to like but why
though why why though so so so let's go
to that so a 55 year old man is married
two kids all of a sudden says I'm gay
okay we had a very like you talked about
earlier right okay we had a very good
friend drop that gorgeous girl married
to a a very famous guy in La who's done
very well billionaire money guy all of a
sudden one day she's like nah I'm not
I'm I'm I'm I'm lesbian I like women she
left her husband with two kids and went
and got what another girl and they got
married and now she's lesbian right okay
but what causes that what causes a 55
year old who has been married with kids
like the movie whale right you saw the
movie well I don't know if you've seen a
movie well or not with uh the guy that
didn't he just win the Oscar right
Brandon Frazier that he was a married
guy with a daughter and when she's eight
or nine years old he's a teacher he
falls in love with a student who's 23 he
leaves the wife and a daughter to go be
with him and then the guy he falls in
love with ends up having AIDS he dies
and then later on he eats so much and he
kills himself right in front of the
daughter this whole story I don't know
if you've seen this song No depressing
story at the highest level don't
recommend watching it Brandon Frazier
crushed the acting but the storyline
makes zero sense on how depressing of a
story this is right but why does a 55
year old man all of a sudden choose to
be gay
I I wouldn't have the answer to that I
mean I feel like the biggest proponent
if you wanted to take a guess on that is
is social
um influence is is what is going to you
know groom someone into to behaving or
seeing something in a different light
um I would be a fool to say that you
know when you idolize something that
people don't want what you're idolizing
and so that's marketing and so it I
would I would argue that it would based
on that person's individual life
experiences that brought them to that
decision I know many of women that um
face like sexual assault and that is a
reason why that they go down the journey
it's a pretty dramatic event though it
is and so it's not genetics no but it
would it would be a proponent of that
mental state and changing your mental
Outlook because of the what happened to
you but you see I don't have a problem
with that then that to me becomes a
religion you change your religion is
what you did meaning there's a lot of
people that are atheists at 55 year old
they become Christians well why how did
you become a Christian right you read
about C.S Lewis I don't know if you know
who C.S Lewis is with the book Mere
Christianity or Chronicles of Narnia
they made a book about this guy it's a
phenomenal movie the the movie they made
about him uh divorce letters I think
he's got all these great books that he
wrote right the great divorce he's got
all these things that he wrote screw
tape letters if you've read it's a
phenomenal book screw tape letters this
guy was an atheist Oxford then he
becomes a Christian you're a pretty
smart guy what happened how do you
change yeah I joined a faith and I found
God how do some of these boxers I was
born a Christian now I'm a Muslim what
happened well a life-changing event
happened right that's a religion that's
not genetics that's not how you were
born I am born a man okay but people
influence me to say wow I like that guy
he asked the questions he converted me
right that is a religion I'm joining but
it's not how I'm born that's the
question I'm putting out there right
sense and would you argue then that
straight would be a religion too no to
me being born a man okay is gay gender
is gay agenda no what is gay gays is
sexuality and so straight would also be
a sexuality man and woman are genders so
male and female and implementation on
the application you know how I put you
know a male female now there's like
other this this that that's no so it's
not like male female straight gay it's
male female those are your two binary
genders yep and that's the way I see it
and then you have these people that are
going to determine their sexual
orientation and now from there you're
going to take someone that could be a
man or could be a woman and they could
be lesbian or straight or gay and so I I
could definitely you know see the lens
that you know if we wanted to claim
sexuality as some sort of religion some
sort of belief it would have to be
blanketed across everyone yeah but I'll
show you here like this these are I'm
giving you applications where they say
what is your gender and then it says
female male trans female to male male to
female intersex other
uh uh you know so and then you have the
sexual orientation which you're talking
about which is completely different like
trans okay totally get it so you're
saying uh uh gay is a religion then
straight is also religion yeah because
they're both sexual if we're going to
paint gay as being a religion yeah then
you I feel like on the because I'm the
guy that you would have to flip at the
same way on the other coin and if gay is
a religion then so is straight because
then what you're arguing for gay you can
also argue for straight and it has to be
same on both ways for it to be factual
right I can go to a place right now that
would really get me in trouble right now
if I if I wanted to go there maybe we
can talk offline when I when I bring
bring up my thoughts on this year but to
me an event doesn't uh an event has to
happen for me to become gay
an event doesn't have to happen for me
to be straight
an event has to happen for me to be gay
right a crisis a life-changing event a
person I meet a conversation a grooming
groomer a person that does something for
me to question myself to say maybe I am
and I don't know and then I shift versus
I want to know naturally are there
symptoms and genetics or studies that I
can say this person's gonna have signs
of being gay that's what I want to know
because you know if it is if the
statement specifically going back to the
statement of I Was Born This Way
cool
I actually want to do studies to see
what that means
you know people say I was born this way
so so that's that's so interesting
because you know this trans movement
definitely abolishes that I Was Born
This Way mentality
um and it's that's why I argue like the
LGBT community is very full of a lot of
contradictions
um because if you're born this way if
you're born gay then why why are people
born in the wrong body you know and it's
like it's it's to me I'm very logically
consistent with it with the statements
that I make and making sure that they
are the same on both sides of that coin
and I think that that's why you're
seeing a big shift in people saying
things like LGB without the T
um gays against groomers we definitely
include the T
um we just don't think that this is
something for children to be influenced
by but consenting adults is different
yeah this is uh uh we went through a
whole different rabbit hole
and and trust it was interesting Frank
trust me when I tell you this off camera
at 11 30 at night having a cigar this
conversation gets a lot more comfortable
when you're talking to home team and
everybody yourself definitely than a
place like this because in a in a in a
society like today
um
we have to be forced to think a certain
way that somebody wants to tell us to
believe and have a very hard time with
that I got kicked out of Bible study
from seven to ten years old because I
would say how the hell does a if you
tell me God exists and we just got
bombed 167 times explain to me how God
exists on all these people that so I was
kicked out of Bible study they wouldn't
even send me back they would tell my mom
and dad your son doesn't need to be in
class because he questions everything in
the Bible so they finally said your son
can't come to Sunday school so I've been
that guy my entire life to question
because I'm curious
if I'm born this way prove it to me I
will trust science from both sides not
just PBS not just Fox I want a Pew
research Gallop those who supported the
vax those who didn't support the vax
those who voted for Republican those who
voted for Democrat scientists let's put
some money in there get to work and
argue and tell us you know what here's
what happens 99.8 percent of people who
become gay were converted because
somebody groomed them cool or no there's
12 that are born this way fine now we
have the signs to go based off of that
rather than all these other things that
are being forced down our throat so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]